thank you
[Music]
so welcome back to a very special
episode of the careful boys we're very
careful boys wow and today we are
talking about how it's been one year
since the collapse of UST and Luna going
does this Mark the out of bar so we
officially a year now
yesterday I lost 1.6 million dollars in
a matter of 24 hours I lost 1.1 million
but you guys it worked out in your favor
though right in the end I mean how soon
no it didn't clean but it didn't I mean
my 75 investment is now gone so much
worse right I mean let me tell you the
lie that I made myself yeah last year
I'm trying to help you guys out here no
I I appreciate this is how I appreciate
it this is how I cope is
um I learned to stand up and fight again
but no in all honesty like I opened up
jumbi in Hawaii right the whole point of
that is because I wanted to test my
ability in a different industry outside
of Internet YouTube all that something
that was foreign to me and also
something it was I didn't open up a
small shop it cost me close to a million
dollars to open up small Boba shops you
know they're a couple hundred thousand
dollars
um but I went Prime real estate I went
hardcore I went I went I wanted to
challenge my myself right I don't think
I would have taken it seriously if I had
a reservoir of that much money because I
would have just done what I usually do
is Outsource them paid it out your
Solutions well basically because it's
like if I can find a manager that has
way more experience than me then why
really do all the things that I don't
want to do okay I get to do all the fun
stuff is I'm gonna pay a manager that
does the operational stuff and maybe run
it
and then what I'll do is maybe the
marketing and the videos and stuff that
I'm more familiar with then I'm not
learning anything but that drove me to a
point where I don't have enough funding
I gotta put every single penny that I
got I'm starting over completely it just
felt like I was starting over
and um all I have we cashed you out a
little bit of Luna though yeah like yeah
you know what I had enough just so I
didn't have to go too much into debt to
restart again but because of that it
drove me with the fire to like feel like
I can't lose this and I have to learn
everything so the pressure
created a different mindset of like I
lost everything and now I have to begin
from scratch and that feeling was
actually so fun as weird as it is like I
think like when you when you get to a
certain point of comfort like there's
nothing driving you like the way that
when you first started
going full time on your passions
and then I forgot that feeling because
it's been over 15 years on YouTube so
then once that happened it was like oh
this is what they mean by like
challenging yourself to the point of
I don't know what's gonna happen and it
was so scary but I was like oh [__] I
learned so much and then now I'm out of
it and I'm like
hey that's that wouldn't have happened
if I had a cushion yep so yeah so you
guys were able to at least cash out your
your initial deposits your principles
though right nope well I I cashed out
more than that because I didn't put that
much in I put in 28 000 so I I got to
1.2 million and then I cashed out a
hundred thousand dollars and then
um yeah I saw the rest of it go to
[__]
I think you know to give myself a little
bit of credit it went like 85 cents
for a million dollars so yeah that's not
that bad
I wasn't able to cash out any of my
principles so I just went straight
negative oh
um me too bro yeah so there's it
definitely put me back maybe like 70
grand or something like that
because that's what you put in basically
yeah yeah that's for me personally yeah
I lost a little bit more than that I'm
down for this stuff I went I put in 300
I'm down 150 so let's go
hey dude I yeah put put 28 in but that's
probably my downfall because I only put
28 000 in and I turned it into first
time I turned into 735
000 with OMG
what about the ethereum that was your
first good run oh yeah well that was I
turned that into OMG like oh the whole
oh yeah yeah I was in total right and
that was part of my ethereum to this and
that and then okay move that into OMG
right and then like watch OMG tank ass
from 28 dollars to [__] 35 cents but
then I bought some of that bottom not as
much as I could have because me and
Nikki were trying to buy a house at the
time so like we're saving up for a down
payment and [__] like that but then you
know once
um the market started coming back alive
I knew enough just from watching the
ethereum uh Community sentiment to know
oh man omg's still building stuff this
is pretty awesome so when Nadine was
here in this room and I was telling him
I'm like I think omg's going to 10 bucks
he thought I was a [__] wizard he
thought like there's a day where OMG
went from 35 cents to ten dollars and
Nadine was like Steve Green's a [__]
wizard I don't know how he does it and
I'm like no no it's not that it's that
I'm just paying attention to community
sentiment the community thinks that it
could go there and that changes things
in your mind right sounds like wizard
[__] to me yeah exactly but that that
makes things the the it elevates the
ceiling of something so when you hear a
price of something right it doesn't
sound that expensive if everyone in the
community is saying they think it's
going to go there so that's why I was
like I think it's going to ten dollars
it's just it's like price anchoring
exactly like whatever your expectations
are it it won't shock anyone if it hits
it and if you're in the mix with the
community and you're paying attention to
what people are saying you can you can
actually come up with pretty reasonable
price targets right problem with Luna
it's just that I I got so greedy because
I only put 28 000 in turn into one point
[__] two million dollars and then
it's like oh well I don't have that much
skin in the game so let's just [__]
go let's see what happens right yeah
well when your expectation is 10 mil and
then you're only 10 of it then mine was
2.5 I'll be honest I I really was like
I'll get two before I'll get the [__]
out but that was so greedy because
because I told Corners I mean you did
some phenomenal moves and you didn't
cash out I know exactly but I told my
Corners my crypto Corners right I was
like hey look when Luna hits 50 I'm
gonna unstake and when it hits 100 I'm
cashing out I didn't do it right I
didn't stick to my own price Target
right we talked about it outside I was
in December I was telling you hey Steve
I think I'm gonna cash out and then did
I do it no I moved it into UST thinking
that's cashing out that's that's another
thing so then yeah so then um you know
we get to
the time where it's like oh man I could
really just I remember Christmas time of
2021 I was like man I showed my mom my
crypto portfolio and [__] on 28 000
investment she's like oh it's so sick
you came back and all [__] but then I
really should have maximized that [__] I
didn't but then when Putin started
firing [__] off me and Anthony are
talking I'm like yo Anthony I'm gonna
[__] cash out like 100 G's that's
like a [__] I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
such a [__] and I I apologize to
Anthony I apologize to my wife and I
apologize to my father I was like I'm
sorry you guys married and raised a
[__] because I am cashing out a hundred
grand but I did and that is the only
reason I'm still alive in this game
right now which is wild yeah you learn
from that though I was greedy I didn't
listen I should have cashed out too at
that time you know we were all up
I know and I didn't know I didn't know
what I didn't know right I just knew but
also when you think long long game right
like we're gonna be playing this game
till we're 80 years old it's like when
you see when you think about it that way
like it's not so much like
I needed this I mean I did but the
game's not over I'm still it's like
when when you mentally prepare for it
you know that that's I mean it still
hurts to feel the blows but that's
almost like becoming a pro fighter right
like if you're a pro fighter like me you
go into the ring and you take it like a
man you don't expect to not get hit
you'd be an idiot to believe that you're
like like immortal like you're you're
going into the ring and you've got it's
a battle like it's like and tonight's a
little different right because because
like you know it's your it's your
removed right and you know since then I
was just like okay well you know and
when this happened dude I lost a million
dollars live right I'm doing I'm doing
crypto Corner every night and I'm like
okay well look we're just gonna do it
again right that's all there is to it
we're just gonna have to do it again and
you know since then
in the last six months of woo I'm up
like [__] eighty percent and you look
around the market and most of the
smarties in the market they're buying
shitty things like Cardona stuff that
sucks stuff that if you want to buy it
and just [__] you might as well put a
nail gun to your head
what's the point why live if you're
gonna buy something like Cardona you
can't even buy a [__] Equity stake in
cardano there's so much Supply y'all are
[__] done buying cardano but they
clown on me those Cardinal guys they're
like oh well Steve was in that Luna [__]
and they're like oh cool dude well I'm
glad I'm not you at least I went to
[__] zero but I pulled 100K out what
the [__] did you do with cardano you're
down four percent I'm up 80 in six
months at the same time you [__]
[__] little [__]
it is it is Delta to reflect like a year
later when you are year removed because
because you can kind of see like what
you ended up doing after I remember and
this is like some real [__] too right
when when we were [__] up
there was a point where I was like oh
[__] my life's Gonna Change like the
things that I was like putting so much
time and effort all the dance stuff I
was like there's no point because the
amount that I can make off like crypto
and stuff like that is like 100x what
I'm making in a year for like dance
stuff so there was a part where I was
like genuinely and mentally starting to
transition uh you know away from my
thoughts of my regular hustle and then I
remember when we [__] lose it all
that was emotionally like really really
heavy you know to lose like seven
figures in like less than 40 hours and
nobody feels sorry for you thank you
um no no I'm talking about us the
greater us got it yeah it was like well
cool you should have catch that you
[__] idiots yeah exactly so so and
you know people are [__] committing
suicide at that time so you think you
ate less yeah you had to really I
remember having to talk to really close
friends and they were just like
genuinely be like Yo dude like you know
at least trying to look at the optimism
of it like hey man like you still got
you know a lot of things going on in
life like it's not over about blind
you're you're coaching yourself to
bounce back and then you're telling
yourself you're like all right you know
I'm gonna [__] I'm just gonna have to
kill it in regular life again now you're
removed
I can say that I'm actually like proud
of like what I was still able to do
outside of it I went back to like my
dance hustle you know what kind of back
to the foundation of like what it is
that I normally do and stuff like that
and I actually killed it harder in this
last year than I have in the last like
five years probably because I had this
like back to the bottom like Joe said
yeah there's just this huge just like
this whether it be a part part pride and
a part just like you know uh uh
desperation like like your back's in a
corner and you're like you have to
[__] hustle hard to make it out and
you feel like you've let down yourself
you let you feel like you let down your
wife you feel like you let down your
family you know what I mean but a year
removed I'm like oh [__] I really did
put into play that fire and and I ended
up having one of the most like you know
intense hustles and hardcore success
years that I've had in a long time
because of it so I'm thankful for it I'm
not a [__] Millionaire right now like
you should have been
but you know it's like it's dope to
still see that like you're not it's just
money that's what everybody's telling
you the numbers on screen and it hurts
at the time but it's just money yeah man
it's the numbers on screen until you
cash it out but that was my problem
right I put in 28 000 so I had a lot of
leeway and I've been through so many
bearings false sense of security 100
because it wasn't harder money yeah it
wasn't I wasn't that state right like I
was I wasn't that invested I loved this
stuff already so I'm like oh I love this
stuff and I [__] crushed it like
that's awesome and I crushed it multiple
times cool I'll do it again but I will
do it again and I am doing it again but
that's the beauty right here I am you're
removed and I'm up on the market
compared to most people like [__] 80
and and but that's the beauty of caring
about it loving it like spending the
time on it but many people don't many
people just stay in their stupid
Investments and they don't pivot and
they will never pivot and yes it's funny
coming from me because I'm like adorned
and woogier but the woo thing for me is
just a commitment that I have to the
space it's not about woo it's about
like knowing that I know the process to
get myself to the next place but I'm
also not so [__] cocky that I don't
sit here and go well we went to zero we
went to zero we went to zero like I say
it all the [__] time because it's
funny like like I have to use both like
you can't take yourself too seriously
those people suck so what I mean in
crypto you have it's like a religious
cult so people have the coin but also
there's the marketing aspect of it like
they do want a value pump right so like
if you're if you could get to the
perceptions of people and then they
believe your coin is going to go to the
Moon then you have more people joining
the movement it's a price target for us
it's almost like we believe in crypto
but we're not loyal to a coin exactly
because that's how it's like stocks like
yeah people used to say oh stocks are a
scam whatever whatever and it's like
stocks are here to stay exactly but I
don't believe in one company I think you
should probably just be in the market
though be in the market it's time in the
market right so that's the thing it's
like so here we are right it's today
right the the 6th of May but like the
market
um is basically still alive and everyone
thought this time last year it wasn't it
was dead crypto's dead hey I heard
crypto diet so sorry about that hey I
heard crypto dead how many times did we
hear that like the whole time we've been
hearing it since 2000 what 12. well
since seven since 2017 big time because
once that markets normies came into the
game and the alts came in and then
everyone's like well they're all
collapsed so like you guys are [__]
idiots but no it's just a beautiful
honestly it's a beautiful
um like moment of remembering what
happened but also we're here at a one
point [__] three trillion dollar
market cap if you think crypto's dead
you're nuts don't ignore it right like
don't miss it either
um so yeah how do you feel about it bro
me yeah
um because you're the most neutral
Observer they're good yeah I don't know
yeah I did but um I didn't put that much
I think in total when it went down I
only had like eight thousand nine
thousand in there but I've only ever
done anything you've said to do because
I don't know [__] and uh the extent of
my knowledge is watching what you guys
do and then listening to the reasons so
I don't really care to extend it too
much beyond that
yeah you know but I felt like holy [__]
this is a pretty big [__] thing
that's happening to you guys but then
you also said this isn't the first time
it happened so I wasn't too worried yeah
you know that's part of the game this
one was OMG
um that was like 800 000 for me
and that went down yeah so you guys
talking about that it didn't seem like
you know it if this was the first time I
would be like oh [__] these guys don't
know what the [__] they're doing
no but it's like but because it's the
second time these guys really don't know
what the [__] they're doing the thing
the thing for me the thing I'll be
straight up the same for me is just
selling right because yeah because I
really
um you know make fun of me all you want
for learning going to zero and [__] all
right turn the small Model A Million
Dollars you want to pick them Steve I
this guy is a millionaire uh multiple
times and by the way Steve Steve's uh
strength here is he knows how to pick
him so he it's like you know it's not
just those two coins he consistently
picked out several throughout this
journey where we were able to roll one
to the other it did what he said it was
gonna do but I think yeah we sold it to
roll it into the ultimate right and in
the ultimate prompt but the issue is I
think I lacked the understanding of
basic fundamentals when you when it
comes to investing crypto was my Casino
yeah and I'm just here you know what I
mean like there's there's certain rules
to investing after I failed I started
studying it and I'm like okay so okay so
it's it's pretty normal to take a little
profits incrementally as you go up you
don't you know you don't want to be too
um you don't want to put all your eggs
in one basket because if there's
Achilles heel or it gets taken down your
whole wealth is gone and these are the
basic principles that sound like duh but
it's like age-old ways to protect
yourself if you're gonna do something
like this yeah and we didn't do it and I
deserve losing it all for not following
the basic fundamentals I also know
enough about it to see how often it's
went up for all of you guys and twice
it's Dove so it's like I get the ratio
and I understand enough to know what
kind of an anomaly happened with Luna
and that's not a normal thing that
occurs with yes points it was very
unusual yeah right but that's the thing
you should be able to withstand a
pullback and then still have like a bag
yeah there was no bag to be had that was
a crazy mystery kind of type of model
right and we still don't know what
happened I'm not saying oh we know it
wasn't a scam or anything like that
Anthony's watch the Lakers game piece of
[__] but
um we you know I'm not saying we don't
know I'm saying like we don't know
enough to just judge and say what we
know and that's the thing but everyone
does on the internet but like the the
the thing now right moving forward
coming away from it the biggest takeaway
for me is just that moment that I I
thought I was the smallest the moment
that I thought I was the biggest [__] I
was apologies my wife and my father was
the moment that I saved myself yeah I
kept myself alive in the game and I hope
you know and I know I'll remember that
but I hope that people can kind of live
to fight another day damn right but then
that's how it was like right after that
happened you were back to work and I was
still like all right what's next and he
just went woo and I went cool 13 cents
looks good look at it now like it's it's
why you guys are the best the game just
goes you know what I think also looking
back I'm like the thing that where we
were like working together in unison is
also what [__] us because if one of us
had the strength to go hey we should
cash out at least 50 let's get out of
here and then started that
versus nah we gotta stay in I believe in
it let's go let's go let's go yeah well
that was you know that was the that was
the thing about like the Putin thing as
I was like Hey Anthony like we should
just like you know get the [__] out a
little bit but that's like 10 yeah like
we should we should like you know what I
mean like the hammer on it like there's
no
we're just so like supportive to the
point where it's like oh you're gonna
stand all right I'm gonna stay in
hardcore hardcore you know well that's
the thing too is I'm like man okay well
Luna this time last year it got attacked
UST got attacked slipped the peg went to
80 something cents we rebounded right
they they and since then they've they've
strengthened it they have now Bitcoin
3.5 billion dollars they're gonna back
it with but they didn't have the
mechanism yet so they announced to the
market how to kill Luna and then they
challenged the billionaires to do it
so funny yeah both and then we were like
yeah I'm gonna chill I'll chill here
yeah but at the time it was so it was
such a wild time you didn't even know
what the [__] was going on I was making
14 000 a month on staking rewards jeez I
think I gave a [__] it's hard to let
that go just off stage yeah that's a
crazy insane it was a fun time man I
plummeted it was freaking shooting like
a goddamn Rocket Man the whole Market
was spawning but us yeah
so you gotta buy them ponzis man
you gotta buy the Posies
[Music]
foreign